to talk about that movie the quiet place
mm-hmm
right we did mention it last week or now
we're supposed to but we had to guess we
had a guest yeah um well on my rave
review I have a rave review of that
movie I think I give it an a a solid a
for that movie I believe that that movie
is crafty entertaining it's basically
original it's aliens on a farm no but
the whole like you know sound things
yeah I'm sorry I'm gonna stop talking I
cannot stand how nasally my my voice is
what did you say before this part does
that remind you of someone in
particularly you said I can't stand
hearing myself because I sound exactly
like George damnit
look could I just I want to throw
something out there it's like why don't
you just go to an island oh and the
quiet please yeah I would find like a
little island and then you know I feel
like I think they were just everywhere
that's the idea that I got nothing that
one place huh I think they were
inescapable and our military couldn't
get him well I guess not they just wiped
everyone out huh
they wiped but there were still people
that living there right other camps yeah
yeah but anyone anyone anyone listening
to me it's you know that movie is the
opposite of annihilation I don't give a
[ __ ] what people say you know my I have
a friend a guy I go on YouTube I go on
YouTube and I listen to a guy named
Chris truck man he is a I love him he is
a movie review reviewer my brother and I
love them
I mean if I can get Chris druckmann here
in my podcast anyone that knows him he
has it he lives in Ohio but I would love
to have him so if you know him reach out
oh it's guys great on YouTube yeah he's
a great YouTube guy and he liked
anihilation and you know what I can
disagree with him annihilation was
pretty well acted but it's basically The
Tree of Life with aliens it's just
boring and at the end of it make any
sense
and you you can email me all you want
and go Bobby you know you don't know
what you're talking about you know
you're dumb right but I prefer you know
just the fly
and fresh crisp doing their thing I do
you know going back to the quiet place
would you could do you think you could
survive in that environment
oh my farts alone so I was trying to
think like how would you yeah and your
ass in your butt too far to it or what
what I would do is public you know I
know exactly what I would you survive I
already know what I would do at our know
what I would do is this and this is it
very very good so I would put yeah you
know um like a dildo in my butthole but
it listen listen but it's how long so
it's like a flute but not that flute
where it's gonna whistle but you want
the shape of a penis though yeah no it's
just listen if I'm saying a straw but
much thicker and bigger and just so keep
the hole constantly open right because
what makes the fart sound because this
is what I do in bed I cut my fingers I
spread my butthole up are same here with
my fingers and I it seeps so when she
asleep me it goes like that right so I
would constantly have just somebody like
butt off and then hopefully like over
time it'll just be an older gap yeah so
we just come out like oh yeah yeah it
would be like that oh like that yeah I
could see those monsters me like that
guys why does he have something up its
butthole or they could just follow my
[ __ ] he went this way
you know the trail yeah but so that
would take care of my farts are pretty
loud snoring snoring snoring - well I
would just put something on my nose like
this now you know how they put that baby
in that like that's what I would do I
would bury channel I would live like I
would live like a vampire I would be in
a casket oh that you would do all the
foraging for like well I'm a forager
yeah yeah I think it's pretty easy I
think you'd live underground right you
you'd sleep in a casket
how about laughing well it's hard to
laugh when people are dying
it really is there's no laughter
[Music]